hello today we're going to discuss
mechanisms resistance to AR signaling
inhibitors and castration-resistant
prostate cancer I'd like to remind you
that you can submit your questions
during the presentation but I will
answer them verbally at the end of the
talk the objectives for our talk today
are to discuss first the continued role
of Angela receptor signaling and
castration-resistant prostate cancer to
review the signaling pathways involved
in the development of resistance to AR
access inhibitors to review novel agents
that are currently in clinical
development and emerging data on
mechanisms of resistance to these agents
and finally to discuss issues in
determining optimal sequencing and
combination treatment strategies for
patients with castration-resistant
prostate cancer androgen deprivation
therapy or ADT remains our most
effective treatment for advanced
prostate cancer however it's also
uniformly characterized by progression
to castration resistant disease which is
the lethal form of the disease
historically progression has been
thought to reflect ligand-independent
reactivation of the Android receptor
signaling pathway however as we will
discuss substantial evidence suggests
that cr.pc arc estimation resistant
prostate cancer retains a clinically
relevant addiction to the AR axis and
remains both ligand and
androgen-dependent this is a schema of
androgen axis in prostate cancer it
depicts the primary source of
circulating androgens the testes and the
adrenal glands the hypothalamus at the
top is responsible for stimulating
pituitary production of LH and FSH which
stimulates testicular androgen
production circulating testosterone can
then enter the cell detected on the
right part of the slide and be converted
to DHT and be converted to DHT which is
a more potent form of androgen
which can then bind to the androgen
receptor and stimulate a are mediated
gene expression castration can be
achieved either by surgical castration
or more commonly by medical castration
using gnrh agonists which inhibit that
hypothalamic pituitary axis agents such
as 5-alpha reductase inhibitors which
prevent the conversion of testosterone
to DHT or antiandrogens which block the
AR can be used to potentiate inhibition
of the AR axis importantly while
castration eliminates testicular
androgen production the cellular AR axis
is still on in a majority of cr.pc
tumors this is thought to be driven by
residual tumor androgens derived from
either the uptake of circulating adrenal
androgens or the intramural synthesis of
androgens as well as alterations in the
AR which potentiate its activity this
slide depicts a number of the mechanisms
proposed to mediate AR activity and
castration-resistant prostate cancer
early in disease is shown at the bottom
of the slide faulty repair of DNA breaks
that occur during a are driven
transcription can lead to oncogenic
rearrangements such as the prevalent TMP
rss2 org fusion product which we'll
discuss later in the presentation on the
left hand side of the slide mechanism is
related to ligand driven activation are
shown in particular the AR can be
activated by residual intratumoral
antigens as we discuss from adrenal or
into tomorrow synthesis it can be
activated by alternative ligands such as
adrenal androgens progesterone or
antiandrogens in the setting of specific
AR mutations the AR protein itself can
undergo changes which potentiate its
activity including AR amplification or
overexpression AR mutations or
ligand-independent AR splice variants
alterations and co regulatory molecules
that potentially
air activity have also been identified
in castration-resistant prostate cancer
finally the AR can be activated by cross
talk with other signaling pathways such
as il-6 her to EGF for the pi3 kinase
pathway this slide is a summary of these
AR related mechanisms of resistance
which we will now discuss in more detail
we'll begin by reviewing data regarding
the activity of residual tumor antigens
and cr.pc tumors this slide shows that
persistent tumor antigens are detected
in cr.pc metastases in conjunction with
ongoing AR transcriptional activity the
panel on the left is depicting tumor
testosterone levels that were measured
in prostate tumors obtained from men
with castration-resistant prostate
cancer on the right hand side there are
eight patients and one through m84 which
for each of which 223 cr.pc tumors were
evaluated to note these tumors were
obtained through a rapid autopsy program
you can see that the testosterone levels
in these tumors are significantly higher
than the controls on the left hand side
the controls include prostate tissue
from men with primary prostate cancer
who are not under androgen suppression
this highlights the significant
difference in tumor androgen levels in
cr.pc where men are castrate and in
primary tumors where men have not been
castrated on the right hand side we are
looking at the expression of the AR
itself as well as PSA a common and
regenerated gene at the transcript level
and by IHC and by both mechanisms you
can see that both the AR and the PSA
continue to be expressed in
castration-resistant prostate cancer
this slide depicts the androgen
metabolic pathway it is important to
review several components of this
pathway in order to understand the
source of tumor antigens in cr.pc as
well as the novel agents that have been
designed to target this pathway
androgen synthesis proceeds from
cholesterol in the upper left-hand
corner through the progesterone
intermediates and then to the adrenal
androgens DHEA and AED via the
sequential activity of sip 17a which is
shown in red the adrenal androgens are
then converted to testosterone and DHT
in cr.pc an important source of tumor
androgens is thought to be the uptake
and conversion of circulating adrenal
androgens the numerous of studies have
demonstrated the presence of the enzymes
required for the conversion of adrenal
androgens to testosterone and DHT and
cr.pc tumors as well significant data
suggests that prostate tumors are
capable of de novo androgen production
from cholesterol itself the inset in the
bottom left panel shows the expression
of 17 by IHC staining and a number of
bone and cr.pc metastasis which would be
a requirement for these tumors to engage
in androgen production as you can see
whether androgen production and tumors
is derived from adrenal androgens or de
novo synthesis from within the tumor sip
17 is the key enzyme that's required for
androgen synthesis and this is the
target of the new ligand synthesis
inhibitor abiraterone or zytiga there
are several things I want to point out
before we move on first several pathways
to DHT synthesis have been proposed the
classical pathway is shown by the gray
arrows from progesterone to DHEA AED
testosterone and DHT however alternate
pathways which bypass the protection of
production of testosterone have also
been demonstrated including the backdoor
pathway which is shown in the blue
arrows and another pathway called a 5 a
dial pathway shown in the blue hatched
arrows it is important to note that in
these alternative pathways the same
enzymatic steps are required as in the
enzyme as in the classical pathway the
only difference is the order in which
these enzymatic conversions occur as
such the same enzymes are
required to be targeted for therapy
second is when patients are treated with
a sip 17 inhibitor abiraterone this not
only results in a decrease in adrenal
androgens but also blocks production of
cortisol which is produced from seven
alpha hydroxy progesterone this leads to
a feedback increase in ACTH which
stimulates the adrenal gland in order to
try to overcome the block of 617
inhibition however due to the ongoing
presence of the agent this results in
increased synthesis of
mineralocorticoids which is derived from
pregnenolone this is responsible for
most of the side effects associated with
a burrata rune and as the reason why
prednisone is given with abiraterone to
prevent this ACTH feedback increase in
hormone finally on the right hand side
of the slide I've shown that
enzalutamide is the agent which is
currently the novel agent currently
proposed to target DHT this slide
demonstrates some of the data supporting
the idea that prostate tumors are
capable of carrying out their own
hormone synthesis in order for this to
occur the tumors have to express not
only sip 17 but the entire complement of
enzymes required for hormone synthesis
on the left hand side are three tumors
tumor one two and three four which
serial sections have been made and
stained with either the androgen
receptor or four of the key enzymes
required for hormone synthesis in these
three examples we see that there is
coordinate expression of each of these
proteins within the same tumor on the
right hand side is a summary of a number
of different cr.pc tumors each column is
a tumor and each row is the antibody for
which it was stained we can see on the
left hand side that a number of tumors
are blue they express no androgen
receptor and our like and are unlikely
to be good targets for a are mediated
therapy however a subset of enzymes
clearly expressed both the AR as well as
the coordinate expression
of a number of the Sarah Jennings imes
and these would be good targets for and
for agents that target miss teratogenic
pathway or the androgen receptor a less
commonly recognized but potentially
important mechanism is the active
transport of steroid into cr.pc tumors
in contrast historically it's been
thought that steroids simply diffuse
into cells however the 0 ATP or SL
co-transporter family has been shown to
import steroids and sulfated precursors
actively into stereo genic tissue
importantly functional snips in these
two genes have been shown to impact the
efficiency of androgen uptake and have
been associated with time to recurrence
and castration-resistant prostate cancer
the figure on the left simply
demonstrates increased expression of a
number of these transporters and cr.pc
tissue compared to either benign
prostate or primary prostate cancers and
on the right this is demonstrated at the
IHC level so thus far we have talked
about residual tumor androgens and cr.pc
metastasis I've shown you that standard
hormone deprivation results in
incomplete suppression of tissue
androgens and in particularly in
prostate cancer metastasis there are
significantly elevated levels of tumor
antigens that are well above the level
required to activate the androgen
receptor importantly cr.pc tumors may
also be capable of synthesizing these
androgens from scratch as well as from
the active uptake of adrenal androgens
as such novel treatment strategies have
to effectively target both systemic and
hormonal androgen sources next we will
talk about some of the AR protein
changes that are involved in AR access
related mechanisms of resistance these
include amplification mutation and in
particular the generation of
ligand-independent slice variance we
will briefly discuss Co regular
alterations that stabilize a are driven
transcription as well as the involvement
of AR and
mediating oncogenic rearrangements this
is a schema of the androgen receptor
showing the different domains of the AR
as well as the areas that are important
that are potentially important as
mutational hotspots the AR is a in
structure has four key domains on the
left hand side is the n-terminal domain
followed by the DNA binding domain a
hinge region and the ligand binding
domain each of these regions has
important functions in mediating AR
transactivation including a are binding
or including Android and binding by the
ligand binding domain as well as Co
Aguilar binding throughout the molecule
with respect to mutations these are rare
and therapy naive men that have been
discovered in 15 to 45 percent of men
with cr.pc these mutations have various
functions but in general they all act to
increase the activation of the AR at low
androgen levels these include those that
impart sensitivity specifically to low
androgen levels or abroad and ligand
sensitivity to either adrenal androgens
progesterone estrogens corticosteroids
as well as allowing antagonists such as
casodex or bicalutamide to actually have
agonist activity importantly with
respect to the new anti-androgen and
dilute amide a mutation that also causes
and saludo my to have agonist activity
has recently been described and will be
discussed later an important concept
that has recently been discovered in
castration-resistant prostate cancer is
the presence of ligand-independent
splice variants here are depicted two of
the most common variants depicted and
found in cr.pc tumors these include the
arv seven and the ARB five six seven in
both these variants key domains of the
antigen receptor have become deleted in
both cases the ligand binding domain is
the primary domain it is missing and
this deletion is responsible for the
constitutively active
of these variants in a RV 7 the first
exon 1 becomes spliced alternative exons
2 & 3 which are cryptic and located
within intronic regions in a RV 567 this
variant is generated by deletion of
exons 5 through 7 and slicing of exon 42
X on 8 in both cases loss of the ligand
binding domain means these receptors do
not bind to androgen and in fact are
constitutively in the nucleus in the
absence of androgen this slide is only
to emphasize that a number of different
AR splice variants have been identified
although to date functionally the
clinically functional ones appear to be
the two previously mentioned this is
some of the data regarding the potential
importance of increased AR variants in
castration-resistant prostate cancer on
the left hand slide is a waterfall plot
showing the expression of AR variance in
either benign tissue primary prostate
cancers or on cr.pc tissue and you can
see that there are increased expression
of a RV 7 in cr.pc tissues on the right
hand side is depicted
immunohistochemical staining of cr.pc
metastases for either an n-terminal or a
c-terminal AR antibody importantly good
antibodies for these AR variants have
not yet been obtained because they do
not have a unique sequence at the end
due to the deletion as such differential
staining of N and c-terminal targets can
indicate the loss or the presence of
truncated variants so the presence of
n-terminal staining but the absence of
c-terminal standing would reflect the
presence of an AR variant and in the
middle section you can see of these
autopsy patients 43 of them demonstrated
higher standing of the at the n-terminus
with loss of c-terminal staining
consistent with the expression of CRP
cement as disease in other studies
markedly increased expression of both
variants has also been demonstrated in
bone and soft-tissue cr.pc metastases
importantly expression of these variants
has already been demonstrated to have
clinical associations so expression of a
RV 7 at the transcript level on the left
has been associated with the risk of
biochemical recurrence after
prostatectomy on the right hand side we
see that the highest quartile of
patients expressing a RV 7 or any
expression at my RV 567 in cr.pc bone
metastasis is associated with a
decreased survival these data suggests
that the presence of the variants are
important in driving AR activity and
aggressive growth in cr.pc tumors the
ability of these variants to maintain a
or activity in the absence of ligand is
depicted in this slide on the left hand
slide we are looking at on the left hand
slide we are looking at staining for the
AR in the presence or absence of DHT in
the left and the top two panels we see
that AR expression is cytoplasmic in the
absence of DHT but because nuclear when
DHT is given this is for full length AR
which is shown at the top of both panels
however in the presence of either a RV 7
and the lower left or ARB 567 AR
staining is constitutively nuclear even
in the absence of DHT on the right hand
side we see that AR variants respond
poorly to agents that target the
c-terminal domains in particular whereas
expression whereas an AR reporter is
inhibited by whereas an AR reporter and
Link app cells is inhibited by the
presence of M DV this is the left panel
of this figure on the right hand side we
see if the link app cells have now been
engineered to overexpress AR fig five
six seven that first there's increased
basal AR activity shown by the
white bars and that in the presence in
the presence or absence of our 1881 MDB
is not able to inhibit AR activation in
the bottom slide we see the impact of
trying to target a different domain of
the androgen receptor which will be
important later on in this discussion in
the right hand panel in the columns that
are labeled epi 001 we can see that this
agent which targets n-terminal domain is
effective against link app cells that
overexpress ARB 5 6 7 whereas
bicalutamide is not an ongoing
controversy in the field relates to how
androgen slice variants are generated
the chief proposed mechanisms are either
intragenic rearrangements or alternative
splicing by the in the genomic mechanism
either exon deletions or focal copy
number increases in alternative exons
within the AR locus have been
demonstrated to favor synthesis of
truncated isoforms in this respect
modest increases in focal gene content
between exons two and three and three
and four have been demonstrated in about
twenty percent of metastases from cr.pc
patients an alternative mechanism that
explains the more dynamic nature of
splice variant expression is alternative
splicing in the right-hand part of the
figure is simply shown that for both AR
expression in black or a rv7 expression
that induction of the variant or
suppression of the variant can be
achieved over 24 hour time period
depending on the presence or absence of
M DV so in particular in the right hand
portion of these figures we see that
after if to if the cells are initially
incubated with mdv this causes induction
of both AR expression and a rv7
expression and then if the cells are
fitted with DHT within 24 hours this
causes
of either full length or AR variant
expression which supports more dynamic
mechanism than genomic rearrangement is
likely that both mechanisms will be
found to play a role alterations and AR
co regulators are another important
mechanism by which the a excuse me the
AR influences cr.pc progression the
schematic shows that upon ligand binding
the AR dissociates from its chaperones
the heat shock proteins can dimerize
enter the nucleus and bind to DNA where
i can initiate transcription do the
recruitment of various co regulatory
molecules this schematic on the right
shows that these the binding of these co
regulators is distributed along the
length of the AR in particular you can
see a number of co regulars bind to the
ligand binding domain which could have
an impact on how AR variants which lack
this domain mediate androgen
transcription this slide is a summary of
some of the AR Co regular alterations
which have been described in cr.pc
importantly many of these changes are
simply involved in potentiating AR
signaling and castration-resistant
prostate cancer particularly at low low
ligand levels either by stabilizing the
AR or increasing its sensitivity the red
arrows denote some of these mechanisms
more recently it has been understood
that the recruitment of CO regulators
and induction of transcription does not
happen in a linear process on the right
hand side of the slide you can see that
the initiation factor is binding to the
DNA this opens the DNA and allows
binding of the androgen receptor or
steroid receptor to an nuclear response
element however instead of a simple
linear model where Co regulators are
then assembled and transcription occurs
it has now been understood that the
initiating factor the pioneering factor
and the are--or nuclear receptor binding
site can be quite distant from each
other in terms of the location on the
chromosome and that they are brought
into close proximity by chromosomal
looping on the left hand side is shown
the another schematic of this looping
and some of the key cofactors that are
involved in mediating AR activity
including Fox a1 and med 1 importantly
dysregulated recruitment of these
factors has been demonstrated to lead to
a proliferative transcript transcriptome
in CRP see the significance of this
looping mechanism is that faulty repair
during a are driven transcription can
actually cause genes that are just
distant from each other on the gene to
be fused together and in fact this is
one mechanism another mechanism whereby
the AR can mediate cr.pc the development
and progression so normally a are driven
transcription involves regulated DNA
breaks these can either be repaired
correctly with induction of
transcription they can on the right and
the right hand circle in the left hand
figure these can if not repaired
correctly can lead to senescence and
dormancy but importantly faulty repair
can lead to a are mediated genomic
rearrangements and this is thought to be
the mechanism by which the AR drives
generation of the prevalent tempers to
ERG fusion which is shown on the right
hand side of the panel induction of
androgen regulate gene expression by the
AR at the tempers to promoter occurs but
due to looping and illegitimate repair
the promoter of the tip vs. to gene
becomes fused to the earth oncogene the
importance of this is that for prostate
cancer is that it is bringing is the
juxtaposition of an androgen during gene
next to a potential oncogene on the
right hand side has shown a summary of
the many different prostate cancer gene
fusions that have been identified the
Uniting characteristic is is generally
the presence of an AR regulated gene
next to a nets family gene member
importantly the ettes family or eric has
been shown to regulate the expression of
multiple target genes that are
associated with cancer initiation and
progression we've now discussed that
many of the AR access related mechanisms
related related to prostate cancer
progression having discussed these
various mechanisms we will now turn to
discussing mechanisms of resistance to
novel AR access inhibitors importantly
nearly all patients who progress on
abiraterone or enzalutamide do so with a
rising PSA suggestive of PS of AR
reactivation in the figure you can see
staining for the AR in a bone biopsy
from a patient who r occurred on
abiraterone this the AR staining is
shown in red and you can see there is
significant retention of nuclear
staining in this patient who is now
abiraterone resistant notably the
emerging data suggests that resistance
to these agents is due to multiple
potential across resistant mechanisms
that are all still directed at
maintaining a are signaling
in particular if we look at the
mechanisms that we have already
discussed a number of them have already
been identified as mediators of
resistance to these AR access agents
including expect evasion by
non-canonical ligands induction of
residual tumor antigens AR
overexpression mutation and induction of
splice variants will now examine in more
detail these mechanisms the evidence for
these mechanisms in resistance to first
abiraterone and then to enzalutamide
this slide shows a responsive to cr.pc
prostate cancer xenografts to treatment
with abiraterone in the top row is the
loo cap 23 xenograft and the left upper
left panel we can see that at seven to
21 days after castration levels of
testosterone and the xenograft are
markedly reduced and remain suppressed
in the recurrent tumors in the next
panel we see that similarly DHT levels
become suppressed at short time points
after therapy and remain suppressed in
the bottom panel we see that for both
testosterone and DHT in this Xena graph
the blue cap 35s in a graph that their
suppression of these hormones at the
short time points however a subset of
the recurrent tumors in this Cena graft
show partial reconstitution of tissue
tee and DHT levels notably this is
accompanied at the transcript level by
increases in RNA transcripts encoding
steroidogenic enzymes including 17 as
well as others and recent data proposes
that a one mechanism of resistance to
abiraterone may actually be selection of
an activating mutation and another key
steroidogenic gene HSD 3 beta 1 in
addition to increases in tumor androgens
changes in both full-length AR and AR
splice variants have been described in
these tumors following abiraterone
therapy in the top row we see that in
lieu cap 23 there's approximately two
fold induction of AR
as well as increases in a RB five six
seven and similarly to recap 35 there's
three to five fold induction of both a
full-length AR and android interceptor
variants these data strongly suggest
that the air axis is still driving
recurrence in these tumors either
through induction of androgen levels or
through increased AR protein expression
another potential mechanism of
resistance is the development of a are
mutants a very interesting observation
that has recently reported our case
reports of patients having an anti
abiraterone withdrawal response we see
here a patient who has been treated for
his prostate cancer he shows an initial
decline in PSA following hormone therapy
and then following docetaxel he starts
abiraterone acetate with a nice fall in
PSA but it recurrence when his
abiraterone is discontinued there is a
steep decline in his PSA level this
response is has been characterized with
patients who have been treated with anti
androgens and has been thought to
reflect the fact that anti androgens
gain agonist activity over time it is
less clear how abiraterone would start
to induce agonist activity notably
abiraterone is a week AR antagonist and
thus it is possible that over time the
two the androgen receptor could evolve
to use abiraterone as an agonist however
another potential mechanism is that
there may be selection for promiscuous
AR mutants that are capable of being
activated by the progesterone
intermediates that are driven that are
that are increased within abiraterone
treatment or by the exile initially
given steroids that are intended to
prevent the ACTH driven side effects
with respect to enzalutamide mechanisms
involving both the AR and androgen
levels have similarly been described
a recent assemble recent studies have
shown that a specific mutation in the
energy receptor called f eight seven six
l confers resistance both ends allude
amide and the next generation version of
this drug called AR and 509 on the
left-hand panel we can see that link cap
cells that express this mutation I'm
sorry link app cells that have the wild
type AR are sensitive to suppression by
AR and 509 however on the right hand
side link at cells that express the AR
with the mutation are no longer
sensitive to either air and 509 or
enzalutamide interestingly tissue
samples from patients have actually
shown induction of this AR mutation over
time suggesting that this may be an
important mechanism resistance in
patients who have progressed on this
drug this slide shows specific more
specifically a schematic for how the AR
antagonists can be converted into
agganis across the top row is treatment
with the antagonist bicalutamide
initially this puts the AR and a
confirmation that cannot bind to the DNA
however a known mutation in that occurs
in the AR w 741 see alters the structure
of the Android or receptor so that
bicalutamide can now bind in an
activating format which allows DNA
binding and activation Erin excuse me
enzalutamide was specifically designed
so that it would not activate this
particular AR mutation however over time
a different mutation has developed which
again allows the antagonist to bind the
AR and activating confirmation in panel
F is shown a next-generation AR
antagonists which has been designed
to forestall development of the F 876
mutation or if it occurs to allow to
prevent binding of enzalutamide to to an
convert this to an agonist confirmation
in addition to a are mutations induction
of androgens and I are sliced variants
following enzalutamide treatment has
also been described this is an example
of mdv resistant vcap cells which were
placed in to castrate mice that were
treated with MBV on regrowth a number of
tumors were harvested and interrogated
for intratumoral androgen levels and
expression of AR isoforms across these
10 tumors we can see that there is
significant heterogeneity both with
respect to androgen levels as well as
expression of AR variance this suggests
that all these mechanisms are
potentially operative and that the same
mechanism resistance is not necessarily
going to be employed by all tumors an
important concept which has recently
been described is the potential
cross-resistance of AR pathway
inhibitors with taxane therapy it has
recently been shown that taxanes
actually inhibit microtubule mediated AR
nuclear translocation and that clinical
responses to taxane therapy correlate
with AR sequestration in the cytoplasm
in circulating tumor cells from patients
who are undergoing therapy the schema on
the Left shows the transit of AR to the
nucleus on the microtubule bound to the
dining motor and that docetaxel or
taxanes can inhibit this translocation
in the bottom right-hand side across the
top row we see an R 1881 cells in the
right-hand panel that there is nuclear
AR staining in the green in contrast
across the bottom row if the cells are
pretreated with tack pack
taxol in this case this prevents the
accumulation of AR in the nucleus with
upon our 1881 or androgen treatment
furthermore a common AR splice variant
that we reviewed before a RB 7 has been
proposed to actually lack the
microtubule binding sequence and
therefore to be less sensitive to tax a
mediated nuclear transport the
importance of this potential
cross-resistance has still not been
elucidated but it demonstrates that
patients who have progressed on AR
access inhibitors may have developed a
our resistance mechanisms that could
influence their sensitivity to
subsequent taxane chemotherapy finally I
would like to discuss some of the
emerging strategies for targeting the AR
axis of these potentially the most
important one our new agents that are
targeting the n-terminal domain of the
androgen receptor to date all of the
androgen receptor antagonists target the
ligand binding domain similarly all the
mechanisms which are directed at
inhibiting ligand synthesis are
ultimately affecting the ligand the
activation via the ligand binding domain
an n-terminal inhibitor would would be a
novel approach that would potentially
allow several benefits compared to
inhibition of the ligand binding domain
which we will discuss in a moment the
reason the intermol has not been
successfully targeted before is because
it has what is called an intrinsically
disordered structure and the right-hand
panel this is depicted at the top by the
blue blue curvy line and what this means
is that the n terminus of the AR does
not obtain an organized structure unless
it is either bound by co regulators by
binding to DNA by binding to ligand or
due to post translational modifications
thus in its native state it is unclear
what its formation is and therefore it
is very difficult to target however
recently several classes of inhibitors
that successfully target the ten
terminal domain have been described
this is shows the structures of some of
the new agents that have entered
practice in particular abiraterone is in
the right hand top and by an M DV which
is enzalutamide is in the bottom the
novel agents that are able to target the
n-terminal domain include this until
provides which have been developed by
maryann sedar at ubc as well as peptidyl
mimetics which can intercalate into the
ER developed by ganesh raj the reason
why n-terminal inhibition may be more
effective than c-terminal inhibition is
due to the multiple mechanisms which may
be engaged in particular an n-terminal
inhibitor would block interaction with
coactivators required for air activity
because many coactivators bind to the
n-terminal domain this type of inhibitor
would disrupt the n and c-terminal
interaction which is required for DNA
which is required for AR dimerization
and effective DNA binding this agent
would as with MDD would prevent binding
of AR to the androgen response elements
but importantly and in contrast to the
ligand binding inhibitors this inhibitor
does not bind the ligand binding domain
so it is not susceptible to competition
by increased levels of androgens as well
it retains this agent would retain
activity against constitutively active
slice variants which lack the ligand
binding domain in the last few slides I
will review some of the current thoughts
with respect to optimizing treatment
strategies importantly there have been a
number of lessons from infectious
disease such as the treatment of
tuberculosis or HIV showing that
sequential therapy is doomed to fail and
that potent combination treatment
strategies are far more likely to be
successful for effective therapy with
respect to prostate cancer this involves
several potential combinations that
could either target multiple nodes of AR
action including ligands and this is an
inhibition new members of AR stability
such as hsp90 or hsp27 inhibitors agents
that can impede AR translocation such as
tax liens
and then DNA binding inhibitors such as
md b FP 001 pepto and peptidomimetics
and finally certain agents are being
developed to promote AR degradation so a
combination of agents that target
multiple sites of AR activity may be
more potent in blocking a or activation
and preventing the outgrowth of AR
resistance as well it is likely that
combinations of AR AR pathway inhibitors
with inhibitors of other signaling
pathways are likely to be important for
example pi3 kinase and m4 pathways are
known to be upregulated in cr.pc tumors
and particularly after erina bishan can
begin to further drive prostate cancers
another important issue is optimizing
the patients that are selected for
therapy this slide is intended to
demonstrate that tumor specific
differences in the androgen access
pathway may influence the efficacy of AR
pathway inhibition across the top r5
cr.pc xena graphs that have been passed
in in mice the hormone levels are
depicted by the black and the red dots
either testosterone or DHT shown either
in castration sensitive tumors that is
my set of tumors that aren't passaged in
intact mice or castration resistant
tumors which were those past in castrate
mice and what we can see is that there
is a correlation between the levels of
residual tumor androgens in the
castration resistant tumors with their
response to abiraterone so the tumors
with the highest level of DHT have the
strongest response to abiraterone shown
on the left with Lou cap 3136 in
contrast tumors towards the right of the
graph which have very low levels of
intratumoral androgens have very little
response to agents that inhibit ligand
synthesis so showing that differences in
these tumor antigens can associate with
a magnitude of response to ligand
synthesis inhibition
this is likely to be important in
selection of patients for treatment as
patients also demonstrate these tumor
specific differences in the expression
of AR or synthetic enzymes which may
influence their response to treatment
here I've simply highlighted three
different patterns of AR and enzymatic
stereo genigans an enzyme expression and
prostate tumors patients on the left
that expressed both the AR and stereo
genic enzymes will be likely very good
candidates for treatment with either
abiraterone or enzalutamide the patients
on the right which express the AR but
are negative force teratogenic enzymes
would not be appropriate candidates for
abiraterone necessarily but might be
better candidates for an AR targeted
agent conversely patients in the middle
that expressed neither assertive junk
enzymes nor AR will not be effectively
treated by either of these approaches so
in summary we have shown you that AR
signaling plays a critical role in
driving the development of
castration-resistant prostate cancer
we've reviewed some of the key
mechanisms of AR activity in cr.pc
including air activation by residual
tumor antigens and non-canonical ligands
air protein alterations such as
amplification mutation and particularly
important splice variants the
potentiation of AR activity by
alterations and transcriptional co
regulators and then an introduction to a
are driven DNA rearrangements that can
cause oncogenic transformation I've also
shown you that persistent AR signaling
continues to drive resistance too potent
ligand synthesis and they are inhibitors
such as abiraterone and enzalutamide and
that to date this has been shown to
occur via induction of tumorigenesis AR
and AR splice variants importantly
current antiandrogens all target the AR
ligand binding domain this domain is
lost and truncated AR variants thus
rendering them in sensitive to such
agents as such n-terminal inhibitors
promise more potent AR inhibition due to
disruption of AR and c interactions
which are required for dimerization
preventing binding of AR to DNA and to
co-activators and do their ability to
retain activity against splice variants
that lack the c-terminal ligand binding
domain with respect to patient selection
critical factors are that tumor specific
differences in expression of air
isoforms or androgens synthetic enzymes
are very likely to influence the
efficacy of AR access inhibition and
that treatment strategies targeting
multiple nodes of air activity likely
multiple signaling pathways
simultaneously will be required for
optimal efficacy these are the
acknowledgments for this talk and
finally to obtain continuing education
credits you may go to the bio conference
live website for for evaluation thank
you I'd be